I have a bad back and I need to lose a
hundred pounds any advice on what
exercises to start with to kick-start
things you know you have a bad back and
you need to take care of that and I have
no idea what that means that could mean
so many different things what you need
to do is you need to probably you know
start to figure out what you can do you
probably want to go to your doctor and
say hey what can I can not what can I do
and what can I not do and then doctors
sometimes are overly cautious
so maybe get a second opinion searching
into Aerith but the bottom line is if
you got a hundred pounds to lose here's
what you need to do start moving some
way somehow whether that starts off as
walking where that starts off as doing
some calisthenics whether it starts off
as riding an exercise bike you need to
start moving that's what you need to do
and then you need to fix the diet
because that's where most that weight
loss is gonna come from and that's the
best ways to kick-start things yes and
you know how ok the diet thing real
quick that you know how like certain
things you go into certain situations
and you're hit with feelings or certain
things that you weren't expecting you're
like dang reject feelings you know fall
into certain pitfalls because you like
dang I didn't really expect it to be
like this you know and maybe if you went
in there expecting certain things or
understanding that certain things are
gonna come about you you'd have more
will so the diet thing when you change
your diet if your diet let's say your
typical diet is poor mean typically
that's gonna mean it tastes good in some
way Jack you know what it'd be you know
fast food or just whatever it's too good
yeah
yeah exactly right so it tastes good and
foods that taste good have a certain
chemical reaction in your brain and they
play they go hand-in-hand pleasure
pleasure
so when you when you refine your diet
typically that means it's gonna be less
sugar you know sometimes less fat it
depends on what kind of diet you know
you go on but if it's if it's a better
diet compared to your junk food diet
based on taste and pleasure
yes tastes less tasty exactly right so
it's one thing to be like okay it
doesn't taste as good and I can handle
that that's cool but the chemical
reaction in your brain is basically
gonna be telling you like you need
pleasure you are being deprived of
pleasure and I don't know they're
telling you your brain is telling you
it's not just pleasure it's sustenance
it's yes not just you want you need yeah
that doughnut yeah that was the standard
and people call it cravings
that's your craving but it's one thing
to be like okay craving a I can overcome
that for a lot of people but it's it's a
weird feeling it goes beyond just you
want to know a good way to kick things
off go on a fast man go on a 24-hour
fast cuz I'll tell you what the best
thing about going on a fast
in my opinion is how it recalibrates
your your it recalibrates to things your
actual feeling of hunger and it
recalibrates your tastebuds - yeah
because when you're eating this
beautiful stuff all that tastes so good
and you just you just need more of it
yeah whereas once you go on a fast when
you have a glass of water it tastes good
yeah I gotta stay so good when you and
then when you break the fast and you
have whatever you're gonna have whatever
your first meal is it takes really good
and it's very satisfying because you
haven't eaten any fret yeah your needs
your needs so that's one of the best
things I found about fasting is it
recalibrates those those two things
hunger and tastes and things start to
taste better it's like have you ever you
drink coca-cola right so you're used to
that sweet sweet sweet thing everyone's
known for me because I don't drink it if
I taste it it tastes over the Thomas
sweet over the top and B that's because
I've fasted from having Coca Cola's for
so long that it just is a taste that I
don't even like anymore yeah but there's
a middle ground where hey you can have
it you go wow this tastes incredibly
good but I don't need a ton of it
because I got the satisfaction of the
taste so yeah that's another good way to
kick things off is go on a fast go on a
24-hour fast
you don't need food like I told might
when my daughter was going through her
last wrestling season she was telling me
she says you know dad I was I was
thinking of cuz she's fasting
we're not fasting she's cutting weight
never mind fasting she got weight and
her thing was like you know if a person
can live for 30 days without food I can
make it till post weigh-ins yeah yeah
you know yeah you're not starving as big
Tony btf Tony used to say like you're
not gonna die oh you're gonna die or no
so um I talked to Tony the other day on
the phone it was all fired up we were
laughing really hard today I was telling
a I was telling a story and he was
laughing so hysterically that it was
hard to understand so yeah Dave Tony
yeah that was his thing well you're not
gonna you're not gonna just die you
don't have anything right now so much
about what when you feel like eating
just picture Tony yeah just picture btf
tony sitting there going you're not
gonna die yeah just just be tougher yeah
wrong with you that's such a good I mean
it's real funny when he says it you know
it makes you feel like we're the real
puss but he's he's kind of right you
know it's like you're like oh my gosh
I'm just I've been just crazy you know
how embarrassing is that imagine this
imagine if you had to announce your
stupid pathetic craving crazy and needs
wants to the world yeah you know I
imagine if I had to walk into a room
into a group of people and say I cannot
live another second longer without a
doughnut like that would be so
embarrassing as a human to say that and
yet we think that way and we act that
way we don't say it right but our
actions basically act that way we know
that the doughnut is not needed yeah we
know that the doughnut is not needed
yeah if you were if you were starving
for for 38 days eat a doughnut
if you run day 37 hold-off you might
find a steak it's so bad man you said
you mentioned made me think that it's so
bad that this is an official effective
way to like improve your diet this right
here
don't keep junk food in your house yeah
that's junk food junk food in your house
you can't control yourself yeah and you
ain't nationalised to you oh you know
what this is no big deal I'm not gonna
start that I'm gonna fast in three weeks
anyway so I'm going to eat this whatever
right now that's how bad we are we can't
control herself
I like that idea I just thought of just
having to announce your week thoughts to
the whole world
yeah and how stupid they would say if
you're gonna carry out an action that's
weak you should have to verbalize it
first yeah
I am about to eat this donut because I
cannot survive without it
announce your rationalization to the
world yeah I'm going to skip this
workout you know because my left pinky
is sore from jujitsu three weeks ago
well no well that's just that's a better
rationalization than a lot of ones that
I've dealt with straight up I don't feel
like it straight up that's not good